Some artists say that suffering is necessary
to create meaningful art... but there have
to be limits, right?
Getting mauled by a lion, or driving a truck
off a cliff is the kind of that suffering
seems to be reserved exclusively for those
whose art is the Hollywood film—and for
better and worse, these movies were among
the most hazardous to the health of cast and
crew.
Waterworld
While it's seen today as something of a curiosity,
1995's Waterworld was a spectacularly misguided,
career-derailing failure for Kevin Costner.
The most expensive film ever made at the time,
it baffled audiences with its bizarre mythology
and uneven tone.
"Hey!
Hahah!"
And as might be expected from a film that
takes place on a world covered in ocean, the
seafaring shoot was more than a little hazardous,
and nearly killed several members of the cast
and crew.
Everyday unpleasantness included seasickness
and constant jellyfish stings.
One costly set sunk, and a diver suffered
an almost-lethal case of the bends during
the retrieval effort.
Female lead Jeanne Tripplehorn and child actress
Tina Majorino had to be rescued by divers
when their sailboat fell apart, and Costner
was pummeled by raging winds and seawater
for more than half an hour while suspended
40 feet in the air for a stunt.
Even one experienced stuntman, famous big
wave surfer Bill Hamilton, was lost at sea
while commuting to the shoot on a jet ski,
and had to be rescued by a production helicopter.
The entire shoot was one gigantic risk to
life and limb, all for a film that, well…
"What do you think, Toby?
The truth!"
"… looks like s---."
The Expendables 3
Given the age of the cast, it stands to reason
that the Expendables films have dished out
a few injuries to its stars, but The Expendables
3 really seemed to have it in for its unusually
old cast.
"Age is just a state of mind."
Then-68-year old Sylvester Stallone suffered
a scary fall that necessitated a metal plate
in his back, which joined the one in his neck
from an injury suffered on the set of the
first film.
Co-star Antonio Banderas injured his knee
in his very first take.
But the production reserved its worst mishap
for Jason Statham, who drove his truck straight
off a dock during a rehearsal and into the
Black Sea.
Everybody panicked—except Statham, who calmly
swam to safety as the truck sank into the
depths.
Still, Statham told Jimmy Fallon that he wasn't
nearly as calm headed as everyone thought.
"So I'm like, 60ft at the bottom of the Black
Sea, stuck in the mud, thinking, 'Hang on
a minute.
How am I gonna get out of this?
This is how it ends!'"
While Statham called it a "nightmare," instinct
kicked in and he made it out safely.
Co-star Terry Crews summed it up, saying,
"Jason Statham is a true bad, bad dude."
Roar
If ever a film seemed specifically designed
to threaten the safety of everyone involved,
it's 1981's Roar.
The brainchild of actress Tippi Hedren and
her writer/producer husband Noel Marshall,
it's the story of a family attacked by wild
jungle animals during a stay in Africa, and
it was executed in the most insane fashion
imaginable.
Dismayed to find that you couldn't just rent
lions, Hedren and Marshall bought a ranch
and began raising their own, along with tigers,
leopards, cheetahs, and even African elephants.
Then they went ahead and shot their movie
right there on the ranch with their own children,
working with some of the most incredibly dangerous
animals on the planet.
"C'mon, you'll hurt my hand.
Ohh ohh ohh."
Of course, the injuries piled up.
Hedren was bitten on the head by a lion, and
Marshall was bit so many times he developed
gangrene.
Hedren's daughter Melanie Griffith received
stitches to her face and almost lost an eye
after an attack, and the cinematographer almost
lost his entire scalp to a lion, an injury
requiring over 200 stitches.
Many of the attacks made the final cut of
the film, which wasn't given any kind of North
American release until 2015.
Years later, Hedren estimated the number of
injuries at over 100 and called Roar "the
most dangerous film ever made in history."
Troy
The 2004 war epic Troy was one of the most
expensive, lavishly staged films to ever be
so indifferently received.
It's mostly remembered today for the strange
fate of one of its stunt performers, and for
one of the most coincidental injuries in film
history.
During a scene with many extras, stuntman
George Camilleri sustained a severe injury
to his lower leg, requiring surgery.
A couple weeks later, he was re-admitted to
the hospital, and quickly passed away from
a pulmonary thromboembolism, a common complication
after an injury of his type.
The film's star Brad Pitt, cast as Achilles,
also somehow managed to injure his character's
namesake tendon during the shoot, causing
production to be shut down for ten weeks.
Hurricane Marty also damaged some sets, but
Troy overcame all of these difficulties and
arrived triumphantly in theaters, only to
be met with a solid thump.
Jumper
The 2008 sci-fi thriller Jumper didn't cause
any problems until principal photography had
wrapped, but when it did, it was lethal.
Set dressers were tearing down exterior sets
in the middle of a cold Toronto winter when
a freakish mishap occurred: a huge chunk of
sand and earth which was frozen to a wall
came unstuck, striking three set dressers.
56-year old David Ritchie didn't survive,
and another man sustained serious injuries
to his head and shoulders.
Toronto police described it as a "fluke accident,"
and the incident cast a pall over the highly
anticipated film, which unfortunately didn't
score well with… anyone.
xXx
It goes without saying that xXx was a dangerous
film to make, as the story of an extreme sports
badass who becomes a secret government agent.
Each stunt ramps up the danger, and one spectacular
stunt unfortunately cost aerial stunt coordinator
Harry O'Connor his life, as director Rob Cohen
recounts on the DVD commentary.
"Now, unfortunately, right there, smacking
into the bridge, breaking his neck, and dying."
O'Connor's stunt remained in the completed
film… right up until the point in which
he doesn't clear the structure.
Cohen considered the stunt to be so routine
that he assigned it to his second unit, and
most of the cast and crew had already completed
their work on the film.
Resident Evil: The Final Chapter
The Resident Evil series of films is the most
profitable video game-to-film series adaptation
of all time, but 2016's Resident Evil: The
Final Chapter proved to be just as big a threat
to life and limb as the film's roving zombies.
Stuntwoman Olivia Jackson suffered horrific
injuries when a camera rig failed to make
way for her during a motorcycle stunt, requiring
her to be put into a medically induced coma.
Her list of injuries were extensive and gory,
including having her skin torn from her face,
a severed neck artery, a shattered shoulderblade,
a collapsed lung, a brain bleed, and the loss
of her left arm.
Unfortunately, the incident didn't seem to
lead to increased caution on the set.
Only a couple months later, crew member Ricardo
Cornelius was crushed when a Humvee slipped
off of a platform and pinned him to a wall.
Reports of the accident leaked only after
the film had completed production.
Apocalypse Now
Perhaps no film shoot was as legendarily taxing
on everyone involved as Francis Ford Coppola's
masterpiece Apocalypse Now; that everyone
survived its filming is nothing short of a
miracle.
Shooting on location in Vietnam, the production
was beset by tropical disease, and natural
disasters that wiped out entire sets, but
those were the least of their problems.
Coppola was running a drug-fueled, psychologically
abusive madhouse that was out of control from
the very beginning.
Lead actor Martin Sheen stepped straight into
the worst possible environment for him at
that time.
In the middle of a personal breakdown and
mired deep in alcoholism, Sheen was fed a
steady diet of alcohol and abuse by Coppola,
who brought out the darkness in Sheen's character
by screaming at the actor and telling him
how evil he was.
"Sometimes he goes too far.
He's the first one to admit it."
Sheen would eventually have a heart attack,
yet somehow continued on with the production.
Coppola himself lost 100 pounds, and Dennis
Hopper stumbled through the shoot on an insane
daily regimen of a case of beer, half gallon
of rum, and three ounces of cocaine.
Actor Sam Bottoms spent the entire year-long
shoot tripping on LSD.
Hopper later commented,
"Ask anybody who was out there, we all felt
like we fought the war."
Ben-Hur
1959's Ben-Hur is well-known for its iconic
chariot race scene, which was filmed on the
largest set ever constructed at that time,
covering 18 acres.
It was also at the time the most expensive
single scene in history at $4 million dollars,
and took over ten grueling weeks.
The action-packed sequence was virtually unprecedented
in cinema, employing a "camera car" that put
viewers right in the middle of the chaotic,
horse-drawn action.
Most impressive was this dangerous scene,
where Ben-Hur is nearly thrown from his chariot.
The stunt was performed by Joe Canutt, who
landed so hard that he really was pitched
violently off the chariot and in between its
two horses.
"Well, it turned him a complete handspring
over the chariot, and he managed to hang with
one hand and get a hold of the hitch rail
and turn to flip off into the speeding wall."
He sustained only a cut on his chin, but to
this day, rumors persist that studio MGM covered
up the death of a stunt performer—simply
because it's so hard to believe nobody died
filming that scene.
The Conqueror
The second-to-last film produced by Howard
Hughes would haunt him for the rest of his
life.
The Conqueror was a big-budget flop featuring
a woefully miscast John Wayne as an unintentionally
comedic Genghis Khan.
During the last years of his life, Hughes
bought up all the prints he could find and
watched the film obsessively, perhaps mortified
by its failure, or perhaps racked with guilt
for having basically executed the entire cast.
The film was shot on location in the Utah
desert, directly downwind from the area where
the US government detonated over 100 atomic
bombs between 1951 and 1962.
An atomic bomb at the Nevada test site, 140
miles to the west.
But it's old stuff to St. George."
Eleven were detonated in 1953 alone, the year
before The Conqueror began production.
The risks of nuclear fallout were not terribly
well-understood at the time, and the Atomic
Energy Commission declared the area completely
safe.
They were staggeringly, horrifyingly wrong.
In the decades following the film's production,
no fewer than 90 cast and crew passed away
from cancer, including Wayne, lead actress
Susan Hayward, and director Dick Powell.
A subsequent study concluded that Cold War-era
nuclear testing had killed at least 11,000
Americans.
"When you saw the tragedy in terms of the
families, it sort of… broke your heart."
Since 1990, Congress has paid $2 billion dollars
to residents of the fallout area in which
The Conqueror was filmed.
It was one of Hollywood's biggest turkeys,
it killed one of its biggest stars, and it
just may have finished the job of driving
Howard Hughes totally insane.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!